ouah
[Applaudissements]
vous savez pas comment il aurait lieu
dans quelles circonstances ils auraient
lieu
mais mon but c'était qu'il ait lieu
[Applaudissements]
chaque année on goûte chaque année en 2d
boy à un moment ça ne peut pas des
négatifs que positifs cette année c'est
la cinquième édition d'événements
caritatifs qu'on fait même si c'est le
quatrième est bonne c'est la cinquième
édition et on a à peu près une
quarantaine de streamer dans la pièce
qui se relayent presque jour et nuit
pour faire du live pendant trois jours
qu'il a quand même pas mal de monde en
présence hier il yad'autres streamer qui
font l'événement de chez eux dans leur
studio pour ceux qui ne s'en souviennent
pas il ya la fameuse règle des 25 heures
de ce crime d'affilée à un maximum donc
s'il vous plaît allez dormir quand vous
êtes fatigué alors concernant les gestes
barrières et c'est dans cette salle
c'est masque obligatoire tout le temps
sauf quand vous êtes vice et les fesses
à votre chaise c'est vraiment hyper
important fait cette édition déjà elle
est particulière parce qu'elle était
stressante a organisé cette édition là
on était sûr de moins de choses et on
voulait surtout être irréprochable sur
l'organisation l'image qu'on donne etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
si stressée parce qu'il n'ya pas tous
qui fonctionne
je suis un peu stressée j'adore ça
commençait
mais ça fait trois pas de stress juste
ma lancée on va discuter après ça à
partir en fait pas du stress parce que
c'est le genre d'événement qui ça ne
peut pas être négatif ce qui s'est
appelé code positif l'objectif de
ceux-ci even c'était pas la cagnotte
c'était pas le nombre d'invités c'était
que l'événement ait lieu honnêtement
c'était un seul objectif et je savais
pas comment il aurait lieu dans quelles
circonstances ils auraient lieu
mais mon but c'était qu'il ait lieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évitez de contrat semblait acquis ce
premier volet
[Applaudissements]
ok
la bonne voie
oh
il
des jeux rétro y aura du switch il y
aura du make-up horreur ce que j'adore
l'horreur donc timika power voilà et
puis et puis du blabla et puis on va
rigoler on va crier sur tous et ce sera
déjà pas mal il n'y a pas de petits ou
de gros dont est ce qu en fait chacun
donne en fonction de ses moyens
il ya des gens pour qui 5 euros ça va
déjà être être beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
j'ai aucune idée de ce qu'on peut
espérer parce que jusqu'à maintenant le
public nous avons toujours beaucoup
surpris à chaque fois on disait dépassé
ou égalé c'est impossible à chaque fois
ça a été fait
[Musique]
donc ça nous donne les tendances sur les
deux dernières années et l'actuel on est
sur une courbe de départ qui est
supérieur à l'année dernière même si ça
me surprend mais tant mieux
là c'est très inattendu je dois l'avouer
ça démarre très bien en tout cas dans un
moment où on se recroqueville chacun
peut sur nous mêmes
on est un peu bloquée chez nous faut
porter des masques
il faut s'écarter etc je crois que voir
ce genre de moments nous ça nous fait du
bien mais je pense que les gens qui
regardent ça leur fait du bien aussi
[Musique]
ça salit oui c'est bien lui qui abat loi
toute la journée
je n'ai joué fait semblant comme
d'habitude au printemps suivant le ciel
aurait était tombé mots in a plongé il
dans un lac du connemara
ouah je vous fais des bisous et je donne
rendez-vous demain matin
bisous je serai là toute la journée
jusqu'à demain soir je suis ambitieux je
vous dis vous souhaite bonne oui
[Musique]
il faudra bien
bien
dans le cadre dans les données schengen
de thil
eh bien je vais me marier avec elle pour
le siège je me projette chez des
patients contre la c
[Musique]
alors du coup ces deals qui a tout
organisé puisque c'est elle qui l'a qui
a géré son affaire de vol moi la seule
chose que j'ai faite c'est dire oui nous
notre but c'est de donner envie aux gens
pour qui l'un d'eux pour qu'ils nous
donnent des sous intrigues mais pour
l'association évidemment pour moi 25
minutes par exemple un faux mariage ce
genre d'événement fait beaucoup rire
notre communauté et les jambes a du coup
en plus d'avoir donné pour une asso et
ses bas ils ont pu obtenir une sorte de
petite émission exclusive que je
n'aurais jamais fait or cet événement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
par les pouvoirs qui sont investis par
le event et l'église adriano garenne je
vous propose donc épouser épouse 6 et 26
ème colonne vacances moi je dis toujours
ça et je le ressens et je le vis
vraiment comme ça les gens sont juste là
pour s'amuser ils viennent bénévolement
et c'est en huitième pour le fun entre
potes et ça se ressent en fait
[Musique]
l'histoire il reste 1 minute 9 minutes
environ le gouren la prairie
l'émulation qui a créé l'ambiance un peu
électrique dans la salle
elle est unique en fait et moi je les ai
vu dans aucun autre événement jusqu'ici
et je suis trop content moi d'accueillir
mes potes pour un week-end pour juste
dégager de la bonne humeur
[Applaudissements]
ça paraît très m mais je pense que ça
fait du bien à tout le monde à ceux qui
organisent à ceux qui participent
concrètement en tant qu'animateur et en
public
[Applaudissements]
c'est non
explose et encore 25 heures de la
défense et minutes devant donc c'est
inespéré
quant à lui attendu est donc là on a les
questions de question pour un streamer
qui vont permettre de départager tout à
l'heure tous candidats par exemple à 4h
pour le choisir de sympa suite à la tacc
de konoha lors de l'examen shown in qui
est le seul gay nine être promu thoune
in rage de 10 kg en demeure gigantesque
pour moi d'être à côté de seulement ça
va donc on va essayer de les rendre
fiers et on va essayer de montrer que je
suis pas en phase et bonjour à tous
salut levier 22 l'an dernier a récolté 3
millions et l'hydro uniquement avec la
communauté d
des gamers en face à des chiffres quand
même incroyable décédé en 2007
quel pilote automobile écossais dressant
une série de jeux vidéo sur le monde et
rallye colin mcrae par le jeune et
individualiste sinon égoïste longtemps
ce genre de discours qu'on voit ce qui
se passe ce soir
force est de constater que ce jugement
il est un minimum hâtif sinon
complètement erroné quoi la team pacs
remporte pour mes questions pour ce
n'est peut-être pas le dernier
let's go bien joué merci à tous tout
s'est très bien passé les retours sont
croyants de laver puis voilà quoi c'est
comme ça je vais aller dormir c'est faux
je vais encore l'iphone en huit ans
[Applaudissements]
oh
on essaie d'être habile 4e journée entre
un paiement thuan sézanne
[Applaudissements]
ces messieurs organisé pour couper la
barbe
je me rappelle qu il rappelle qu'il va
des savoirs en live c'est à dire que ça
va arriver là maintenant juste après
celui qu'ils ont été déjà c'est la merde
tout pas mal de streamer sont venus sur
moi sur ma chaîne pour faire un rêve de
fou et c'est pour raser cette bande
saleh de blizzard on va le faire et
c'est le jeu et s'est projeté vers
l'avant garde
[Applaudissements]
je croyais que j'avais mal
ce sera embêtant
sur un seul week-end arriver à une telle
somme c'est complètement fou mais quand
on fait un gala par le mot peur ça peut
rapporter dans les quarante mille euros
en une seule soirée
on voit bien à quel point ici c'est en
1h citoyenne et 40 et heureux on est à 3
millions les sanguines les 21 et on a
encore quatre heures merci
il a fait quoi il semble osé un écran
ça va 4 millions double report pose
event sur twitch mondiale donc c'est
assez ou émotionnellement
pas encore totalement vue là parce qu'il
va se passer trop de choses j'ai très
chaud j'ai vu ni d'humour
euros soit 1 million 700 mille euros
j'ai pas les chiffres exacts
j'ai plus droit
nous verrons plus d'argent les gens sont
trop généreux les gens sont trop
généreux et ça fait très plaisir
le nombre de gens qui ont commis un euro
c'est une 132 mille personnes
s'ils osent event a pu traverser ça
sereinement on voit pas ce qu'il
pourrait arrêter aujourd'hui ça fait
partie des conditions les plus
difficiles dans lesquelles on a organisé
des événements depuis que j'en fais donc
franchement pour moi là le g20 a atteint
ce stade
[Applaudissements]